hello everyone we have another game here
that was suggested to me by a subscriber
and it's well it's definitely one of the
craziest chess games I've ever seen it
was played in 2010 in the Chess Olympiad
in Russia and you can find find it in
the database by the name of Final
Fantasy which is kind of nice because
Final Fantasy is actually my favorite
video game
part 7 that is so let's see the game a
big charity is white and the Java beador
is black we have e 4 c 6 d 4 D 5 the
caro-kann defense charge plays f3 and
already on most raise your Baba plays
Queen to b6 and already a move 3 we are
out of the book we have a three by
charkie develop lazy 5 e captures on d5
and now Knight to f6 offering some
points for for faster development so
Chuckie accepts he plays V captures only
5 and now jabal plays Bishop to c5 and
this is I mean this is taking rapid
developments to a whole new level
he's offering this f6 Knight for four
well what seems to be a strong attack
with this Bishop and I have two checks
coming but big turkey doesn't scare
easily and he accepts the channel and
she plays he captures on f6 Bishop to
have to check King to e2 and Jabbar
castles and prepares the rook to e8
check we have a Queen to d2 by chalky
and I'll rock to rock - eh check King
goes to d1 and now Joe Bala well place
rook to e1 checking the White King and
forces forces forces Chaffee to give up
the Queen so we have Queen to e1 Bishop
captures any one end King captures
anyone and ok white does have three
pieces for the Queen but all of his
pieces are undeveloped and well this
this is going to be a fine game
Bishop to a5 attacking that C to bond
and developing it nicely Bishop to e2 we
have Knight to d7 d captures on c6 b
captors on c6 and now Bishop to d1 at
defending that pawn rook to e8 check and
nice te to develop late night captures
on f6 and now Knight B to C 3
Bishop to c8 and a four
we have a five and rook to f1 Bishop to
a six now this knight is pinned all the
way from the rock end also from the
bishop okay somewhat semi pinned wrote
this - I'm pinning h5 we have worked to
a3 preparing to bring the other rook
into the game h4 by bala G 3h h 3g 4 by
Jackie rope to d8 we have a nice to f4
Knight to d7 rope to b3 attacking the
Queen Queen to d4 Knight F to e 2 now
also attacking the Queen and the devil
plays rogue bacteria - now pinning the
night again so we have Knight to e4
Queen to a4 and Bishop to d2 and devala
tries a queen to a-1 now also pinning
this Bishop um do you want but check
plays Bishop to c3 and we have a nice to
e5 rook to a3 attacking the Queen and
the develop lays the Queen to be one and
now Chuckie attacks us again with night
2 d2 and here chavalla tries the one
last trick to win the game she plays a
queen to c1 and it's interesting what
happens if if Jackie would capture the
screen if Knight captures on c1 and
simply Knight captures an f3 and this is
checkmate and game is over but Chuckie
didn't play a spectacular game like this
fall for silly tricks so after a queen
c1chart simply played rook captures n a5
now preparing to go for this a 6 bishop
we have Knight to g6 by joe bala jockey
plays rook captures an a6 and after
Knight to f4 jockey finishes the game
nicely with a rope to a 8 now pinning
this rook so this knight cannot be
captured and in this position zubaba
resigned the game so a beautiful game
bye-bye Vasilievich ok k big jacket and
this really shows that
you
you shouldn't be afraid of the attack if
someone attacks you you do have to
calculate and wait things out and see if
maybe you can you can get on top and
yeah this is for this video I do hope
you enjoyed this game it's quite a crazy
game but I expected no less from an
encounter like event versus Chihuahua
and as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here but instead of two
my previous videos I will make the top
last video my top ten sex video about
Vasiliev and forgive you if you haven't
seen it yet and that's it thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
[Music]